Throat,
I don't really understand, okay
Doyala,
there seems to be a contradiction
between the memory I made and hers
.
Please take a look at this.
I deliberately set aside more happy memories than the average human being
.
This allows them to have more time to process their emotions
, even in extreme stressful environments such as mobile Luhan.  I hope I can confirm that I will absolutely obey
Please wait It's
neither me nor
you What do you mean it's not you?
Memories don't fade, so I put a haze over artificial things
But I hope this is clear
There's no point in that There's
no interlocking emotions The
flesh Why is that?
Yes, this is a highly processed memory. It
can't be done easily.
Wait, stop.
What the hell is this?
Artificial memory
?
Yes, but this does not appear in the memory of the population.